what's up sweet tits uh you gotta check
out my fall dates all on sale now at
salvolcanocomedy.com
we got uh toronto we have hamilton
canada ontario there richmond virginia
hershey pennsylvania second show added
knoxville uh atlanta second show added
birmingham louisville evansville
jacksonville tampa orlando sacramento
san jose santa rosa all on sale right
now savilecanoecomedy.com merch is up
there too uh yeah that's my next dates
and that's going to be it for a little
while so make sure you get out there
thanks guys
all right and then this head hey folks
joe derosa here from the taste buds
podcast i got dates i got dates i got
dates go to joederosainfo.com
to check them out you can also buy your
tickets there get all the show info you
need
first up atlantic city new jersey then i
will be heading off to san diego
california i am also hitting somerville
in massachusetts after that north
carolina
and some other stuff
joederosainfo.com new dates are being
added all the time and if you're in new
york city come to joey roses if you're
not in new york city and you want to
make a trip come to joey rose's joey
roses nyc joeyrosesnyc.com for all the
info on the spot that serves both
alcohol and sandwiches at amazing prices
opening tuesday through sunday at 12 p.m
every day joeyrosesnyc.com
taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right hey
folks welcome to t-a-s-t-e buds it's joe
derosa here flying solo today without
sal volcano sal is uh taking care of
business uh and uh that's what he's
doing right now so you're gonna have to
deal with me
running the ship steering the ship here
for a couple episodes and that's just
the way it is
uh but i do have some special guests
here uh i'm happy that they are here
they are uh
varying degrees of friends uh
how do i say this how do you say it
ari shafir
i've known longer and is technically a
closer friend but i wouldn't say he's a
better friend i'm more of an enemy it's
steve simone
i'm both more of a friend and more of an
enemy
yeah i know steve way less
but he's better yeah he's a better
player he's not a human for sure than
both of us though
i still can't believe you guys are
friends it doesn't make sense
doesn't make sense at all it reminds me
of uh rick and bob newhart
yes like i remember when i was a young
comic should wait but
at least one of you would have to be
successful
there's still hope
no it does remind me of that rick
morrison bob newhart no no
rick
no doctor
was like rick moranis is an [ __ ]
he shrunk those kids on purpose
[Laughter]
he started with those guys what you
didn't know before the punch was he was
really sh [ __ ] on those dudes what
if you found out either one of them was
an [ __ ] don but bob newhart was an
[ __ ] real ball buster real [ __ ]
yeah didn't tip actually stole money
from other tables
yeah yeah it would it would endear me to
bob newhart who's the well i i i i i is
that bro best
episode of my dollar best
it is pretty goddamn great tv guide blew
it before it came out which is lame but
it ends with
he
has so a second set his first second he
was a psychiatrist and he was married to
suzanne plouchette the act the the
that's the actress that played his wife
second series i forget the actors that
played his wife but but he oh it was he
was a different character and he owned a
breakfast
and they're weird characters
yeah all that [ __ ]
the end of that series he wakes up
in the middle of the night
the turns the light on he's on the
bedroom set of the original series
turns
suzanne plouchette
gets up and she's like what's the matter
honey and he's like i had the worst
dream i've ever had in my life
i dreamt that i owned a bed and
breakfast there were these horrible
people
and he started like explaining it and as
he's explaining it it's killing yes and
then when he goes and then there were
these brothers and the place is going
[ __ ] right
yeah that was that was i got chills like
talking about that
it's a live studio audience and they
were like oh my god yeah they were like
they're going like crazy it's an awesome
awesome ending i thought that
and i didn't have the guts to pitch to
him but i did a uh i was only on one
episode because they cut my character
but i was on an epis i was on a sitcom
called living biblically when i lived in
l.a that johnny galecki is that the one
that nobody saw yeah yeah oh right yeah
yeah yeah i remember that i just got
nervous and i was just like wait better
call saul like until now i'm like
nervous to be sitting next to him no but
i was johnny galecki was uh ep'ing the
show who's johnny galecki from the from
big theory yeah no no
yeah no that that's right isn't this no
that's kenickie kaneki uh
he was ep in the show he became very
friendly he was very nice
but it was at the same time that they
were leading up to the finale of big
bang theory
and nobody knew how big back there was
going to end yet they were like entering
the last season and i so badly want to
pitch i want because it was before
roseanne came back
and i wanted
i was like roseanne she wakes up
wakes up she should show up
she's been there
and be like and just be like we've been
looking for you where have you been you
know you left becky with yes without a
kid not becky or darlene yeah
and like i'm like that's how your
character should lea like and i didn't
have the [ __ ] guts to not that they
they would have just they were not like
would you have said it now are you more
confident now to be like who cares
what it says
and then just been like
dude i think it's a good idea it is
again who cares you know
i called i called the the guys from
better call song and said pitch ideas i
just was like i have an idea of for a
spin-off for my character oh yeah of
course how about every single character
out there yeah you're doing spin-offs
how about making me a star but but it
wasn't that
the idea was so insane that i was like i
it justified me that's great pitching it
i didn't even pitch a picture i called
um it's called the ep this guy's great
that's gilligan i didn't i called this
guy thomas now she's a great awesome
dude [ __ ] him and
i just said do you think this idea is
worth presenting to vince and peter and
i told me i did he was laughing really
hard he was like i don't think they want
to do anymore here he was like but i'll
ask them and i was like okay like but i
was like but it was such a crazy idea
that i was like i don't feel
self-conscious about pitching this at
all i'm not being like and then wouldn't
it be great if see my guy
it wasn't that yeah it was nuts it was
nice but anyway so yes i would have said
it to johnny galactic yeah
i wanna i could probably hear your vet
idea we could probably get the idea to
roseanne right now yeah like he was a
real vet
something went wrong his dog died like
john wick and then he's like now
i'm done operating on [ __ ]
dude i'm reading a book about a real
event have you guys ever worked i'm just
doing back alley [ __ ] i would love to
play
that actually be very funny me just in
the shape i'm in now with my body my
posture but having to do john wick's
stuff yeah and like how sloppy it would
be it would be called fear the pair
[Laughter]
but it works that's the funny part it's
like i'm doing all this stuff and it's
horrible but it works like i am killing
everybody you can train just to make it
look right no but it should look right
it should look like the first time i'm
trying it
but everybody's still dying and that's
what's funny about it
but have you guys ever
the scariest people in the world are
that don't know how to do it no no
completely not who you'd pick up on the
radar they don't look like jack
remember that there was a 60 minutes
once and it was the first time ever they
got and i'm not saying this because
you're here i'm self-conscious but it
was a mossad agent that they caught on
camera
that was an assassin because nobody
knows what these guys look like they're
the best of the best and it looked like
a suburban dad chubby out of shape hairy
legs socks pulled up completely
completely off the radar you would not
know could the scariest part yeah they
don't want somebody looking like and
you know i thought of on the plane i
gotta do a bit about it but like
whenever they meet like like uh you know
double 07 they meet on a train some
worms wearing like a silk
nighty on the train and they meet and
he's just like walking past her and it's
like it's like oh [ __ ] that might be a
fellow spy right and then they're like
so what are you uh what are you doing
here and i'm like that's not the trains
i've been on
where's the fat
kid who was like i want a sandwich
just somebody
excuse me sir no the seats taken that
those are that's very funny those are
the kind of details
that they'll put into like like i just
watched uncharted
and it was actually super fun i liked
the video games a lot and the movie was
really fun but those are the kind of
details they'll put into like um like
that
uncharted's very much like indiana jones
they'll throw like those goofy details
in
where like
like in indiana jones like when the
fireplace turns
and like in every other movie yeah and
then they see them and like and they
start screaming and they're like and
it's so funny like un like uncharted is
this or indiana jones that's a series
where it's like they'd be on a plane and
they'd be having been talking about
something thing and then all of a sudden
a baby would start crying or something
yeah and you'd be like that's what makes
this like a great series
versus everything that's so slick i want
to do a series called uncharted about my
pants this morning
it's set in the past
well listen today we're here to battle
do you guys want to oh by the way do you
guys want to talk about any do you want
to plug anything you're doing it's
coming out right away right
huh it's coming out so i'll be in
philadelphia home will come out next not
not today comes out next monday yeah
i'll be in uh i'll be in uh i'll be in
uh philadelphia at the uh helium club
helium that's this is called
going knight
uh yeah in uh in uh october and uh
i don't know and i'm starting a new
podcast
what is it it's a travel podcast called
you be tripping
oh that's great yeah
yeah one one hour one one place
different people that have been there so
uh you can register now what is it
called not register what's the word
subscribe yes yeah so everybody go see
that that's great in october that's
great
i have absolutely nothing i'm finishing
up stand up and i just want to finishing
up shannon are you leaving well no a
little tour this weekend oh oh oh okay
all right
maybe maybe a prayer for the people to
say to god well that's all i'm trying to
figure out that podcast you told me to
do
this podcast
um you know what i'm gonna announce it
here too because i keep dragging my ass
and if i announce it i have to do it i'm
i'm launching the solo
podcast and patreon and youtube channel
it's going to be called down with joe
derosa it's going to be me
talking about all the things i'm down
with i'm going to be reviewing like
media box sets talking about video games
revealing movies nice
it's going to be all it's going to be
just like hanging out with me
as i sit at my desk
this is the start of every episode
i don't know
100 will be
food it's just me me basically doing a
like talk discussing a lot of things
that i that i really love uh anyway
that's coming soon there but what's
coming now joe what's coming now me
in my pants
[Laughter]
what's coming now is the battle yeah
we're here to battle
what uh
what what are we referred to as guido
meat yeah we're gonna the yeah the
battle of the delis
we're battling salami versus prosciutto
now sal yeah even in his absence yeah
even in my picking up the ball and
running with it yeah booking the guests
creating the battles yeah figuring it
all out let me guess still weighing in
being a downer
right before
we're starting
i don't know if this battle has the
teeth i'm a little concerned god bless
if you wanted because that's how i said
go handle your business
sal he will always sugarcoat it and god
bless so it sounds like he's being nice
yeah
guys i love you both uh it's not that i
don't love you both individually and as
a group but uh i mean why be a failure
you know it's like yeah wait what'd you
say it's salaam i love you the best most
diverse meat there is salami
so ari is team salami i'm t i said this
algo i respect your input prosciutto and
salami have legs these are on every it's
like you've gone to europe because he
dumped weed
and he's like oh it's brushing all the
way no no he didn't think either meat
might be able to carry what
it's a tough battle they're sensational
meets but also too you go overseas yeah
most european countries that i've been
to if you go to their breakfast thing in
the hotel prosciutto and salami on every
breakfast but these cured meats make an
appearance everywhere these are
these are you don't see you don't you
don't see turkey no you don't see you go
to amsterdam now you're not going into a
deli and they have a turkey sandwich
they have
to my favorite italian deli in los
angeles years ago when somebody ordered
a turkey sandwich and he got angry
like he was like who comes to dominguez
and orders a turkey sandwich i should
smack this guy you know what he was
gonna say i was like joey just relax
what is he by the way is he italian or
mexican he's cute he's italian adjacent
yeah okay he grew up yeah
it's like you're not really egyptian
no i'm i'm really egyptian i'm not
really italian but i identify 100 as i
that's how i grew up yeah that's what i
mean yeah yeah same thing oh wait i
forgot before we do the battle i have to
plug this uh uh
this is um
i said i'd wear the shirt uh this is
from
uh
katrina still they're still raising
money for katrina
i'm like dude if you haven't gone
together by now
it's on you
the funds were out there
come on with these charities
katrina genter is her name she's very
lovely she came to uh one of my shows in
atlantic city she's the founder of our
brother's keepers foundation
um that is a dedication to in memory of
her brother chris uh she was lovely i
met her after the show she gave me a
shirt
she
said if you wore this it would be
awesome i'm wearing it for that reason
i'm trying to do a good thing for once
when i'm i'm always on twitter saying i
hope this bicyclist
gets elbowed off his bike and dies and
all these things so i'm trying to say
like i'm trying to do a nice thing here
yeah so anyway shouts out our brother's
keepers foundation for every ten dollars
donated they donate one porno magazine
to orphans in the inner city that's not
true uh it's one of their side things
but they don't have pledges that's not
true one that's a penetration
magazine that's not true inner city
poverty stricken orphans that's not true
that's not true okay follow our
brother's keeper they don't do anything
arie just said let's move off of it
quickly before he ruins it
shut up shut up bonus for losers
stop my brother's keeper foundation oh
visit them at uh uh on facebook follow
them on facebook our brothers keepers
foundation shut up if you can't come
shut up they'll get you hard shut up
shut up shut up shut up i cut it off
right after i said the thing okay i'm
just trying to promote the thing stop it
all right here we go
uh salami and i got shout outs on the
next episode too pimp remind me
people have been bringing me i'll talk
about the next episode we gotta move
salami versus prosciutto i am team
prosciutto of course you're watching
salami are you team either or do you
want to be the judge at the end you know
i'll be the judge no no i don't because
i started simeone you know what the [ __ ]
you are yeah but there's so yeah i am a
guinea i lit i i thank you it's food
that's it all i want out of that another
taste buds first we got a moderator on
site i don't think we've ever had that
pimp this is tough oh wait you moderated
first oh that's right okay never mind
and first guest
that's how that's great first guest last
case first moderator last moderator okay
all right here we go uh hey folks joe
derosa here talking to you about sunday
scaries we all get the sunday scaries
right you know what that is
sunday you go oh [ __ ] you're stressful
you're nervous you can't sleep you've
got dreadful feelings and those feelings
hit you
when the hardest on sunday evening when
you think about the impending doom
of the work week
of what's coming tomorrow of school or
just life in general
i'll tell you this ad speaks my language
my gosh did i write this
uh unfortunately i mean we're talking
about doom
anyway unfortunately you can feel that
scary feeling
every day of the week it's not just
regulated to sunday sunday's just the
name we gave it because that's the most
uh um identifiable day with this feeling
but anyway
you know these oh [ __ ] moments so
sunday scaries the company is here to
help
all right isn't that nice they're here
to help uh sunday scary cbd gummies were
made to defeat the crap that life throws
at you help you relax uh they're perfect
cbd gummies for for uh professionals
if you're on the grind in any way uh for
for moms for dads
students party animals
regretful texters when you're drunk
whatever it is sometimes you gotta just
go oh geez uh let me i gotta relax
uh i don't relax well
uh as you all know you watch this show
uh it's hard for me to shut my brain off
and chill you know here i am in my bar
and i lay at night
in my bed
equally thankful that i have a bar
uh and equally panicked that i have a
bar i lay at night
equally thankful about this podcast and
equally panic that i have to wake up at
a certain time to record it
uh
stand-up comedy one of the great gifts
life has given me maybe the greatest
gift life has given me and i and i oh my
god i have to go on the road and have to
get on the plane and what if the plane
is delayed
this is just how i operate and i know a
lot of you do too
uh this can affect your sleep it can
affect your life you get what i'm saying
check out the cbd gummies all right 2020
let's make it all or 2022 excuse me
let's make it all about self-love and
taking better care of yourself sunday
scary cbd gummies are the answer all
right
we have the relax we have the right the
right
to live scare free all right and i'm
going to give you a 25 discount to do so
visit sundayscaries.com
and use the promo code tastebuds for a
25 off discount that's promo code
tastebuds for 25 off the sunday scaries
at sundayscaries.com
who loves me i do i love it i love me
some meat
boy i love me some high quality meat
even better
therefore i love me some butcher box
butcher box bringing you high quality
meat to your door
for effective prices
cost effective prices
speedy deliveries
wonderful meats i mean i just love this
man butcher box takes the guesswork out
of finding your high quality meat
uh or seafood and you can trust them in
doing it 100 grass-fed beef free-range
organic chicken the pork is raised crate
free they got wild caught seafood it's
all humanely raised no antibiotics no
added hormones none of that crap in your
food
just good quality
meat
get just what you want delivered to you
as well right to your doorstep this is
ultimate convenience what do you want
you get it what you don't want you don't
get it it's that easy and it's free
shipping in the continental united
states and there are no surprise fees
people this is just amazing there's so
many options there's so many different
plans
uh you know you can curate your own box
whatever you want this is it take the
guesswork out of getting yourself some
high quality stuff uh to the on the
plate and just trust butcher box trust
me i love them i love i love i love i
love this service all right so
uh well and i should say what's my
favorite i like the steaks i i find that
steaks are uh
grass-fed steak uh of quality
not just quality because it's grass-fed
quality cut thickness
you know that's got something to do with
it you know you can go into
any old store and find grass-fed beef
and if it's cut badly or it's too thin
or it's too thick it doesn't do you any
good
every aspect of what butcher box is
bringing you is quality and that's it's
just amazing anyway so
if you're gonna get what butcher box get
with them now because you're gonna take
chicken breast off your grocery list
butcher box is offering
our listeners an incredible deal
and they've never offered this before
free chicken for a year
what
free chicken for a year
get two pounds of free range organic
chicken breasts in every order that you
get two pounds of
this for free in every order when you
sign up at butcherbox.com taste buds
claim your deal
at butcherbox.com
taste buds
open up now salami everybody says an
italian meat which is found in a lot of
italian sandwiches uh it's the
cornerstone of many of my sandwiches but
yeah it's a jewish meat it's a lot of
juices
the people said rome said they invented
it but it didn't it's all over europe
says they invented it jews have taken it
because
the jews took something that's right
once we got rid of jesus we took not
only his crown of thorns and started a
fire with it we also
took his salami okay
uh and we made it our own uh here's why
it's better one versatile
hard salami soft salami what does
prosciutto got
that's your versatility heart versus
soft it's got more first of all dummy
small they're all hard there's hard
zombie just means it's a firmer slot
there's no such thing as soft salami
this is deli salami it's just like
deli's prosciutto yeah but it's not
called soft salami it's called salami
yeah and then you have hard salami yeah
you don't have a heart prosciutto
well you want to talk about versus there
are
prosciutto is a term for ham right yeah
pimp back me up on that if you can look
it up uh
but it's time for him
dude i'll take you down to the apollos
in little italy yeah and look at their
prosciutto selection dude it's dry it's
too salty it's moist it's cured in salt
legitimately the root word is without
moisture what do you mean it comes
do you think i didn't do research
[Laughter]
you think that's not dry let's see here
the term prosciutto is derived from
latin was one of yours latin words pro
meaning before and exudus meaning up
without juice which came from the word
exiger meaning to suck out moisture well
as in from your mouth
but because it's a cure salami's a cured
meat hey that's not the root word all
right well listen if you're going to try
to sit here right now and tell me salami
is juicy i mean you're out of your mind
it is juicy or not salty juicy with
orange dry salami is one of the salabies
it is it's one of the main arby's it is
and it's one of the best ones it's hard
it's a romanian staple i hate it what
why it goes good with peanut butter you
can't have prosciutto with peanut butter
what you've had salami and peanut butter
on a salami peanut butter on an
everything bagel oh that's disgusting oh
i wish i should have made one and
brought it yeah
the lack of adventure you have in your
lives both of you is almost unsettling
uh and like wow why am i friends with
him being christian why am i friends
with you for your go nowhere do nothing
at all
how is it adventurous to put a meat that
doesn't go with the
spread on it
like elvis [ __ ] presley greatest rock
star of all time in america by the way
peanut butter on the record on this very
podcast my least favorite of the bagels
i have made it very clear on here though
i don't like that you can't have it on a
on a raisin bagel it's got to be on
everything
maybe on a plain bagel i might start
listening but here's the oh my god dude
so what is that you can hang up a salami
you can hang it on such a get off my
wall what is that this is a heart salami
from romania wow how about a salami for
your son in the army i know
how about this uh get a prosciutto for
your son in the mudo
wait a second wait a second you want to
talk let's talk clash royale let's talk
let's start class let's talk class my
meat my meat comes at its best you can
find prosciutto at 65 a pound more more
yeah
your meals hangs from the ceiling you
pig
you pee it's 65 because the mafia has
gotten their hands in it it's not
[ __ ] good it's just your thing look
at this [ __ ] your meat looks like in
predator when it hangs the bodies up
[Laughter]
you have garbage people i'm telling you
this right now i'm telling you this
right now once the salami jumps out of
italy i want nothing to do with it all
those eastern european salamis blood
blood sausages
not a salami that's sausage that looks
like blood sausage look how red that is
dude it's so good all right cut us a
piece so salty as you complained about
prosciutto
don't mark hold on put something down
don't you don't have any [ __ ] cuts
that rag where'd you get that rag from
from out there in your [ __ ]
do you know if it was a clean rag or not
all right
look at this look at him trying to cut
this abomination i really like salami
but this isn't it's doing look at him
trying to cut it look at him trying to
cut it because it's hardened it's who
wants hardened meat all right that's not
a good thing
oh my god it flew off the table
not really i'll take it no thank you
bite a piece
oh my god it crunched
so [ __ ] good dude you're nuts it's
sending out to harden for a while now
joe
you're nuts i had to set it out to
harden for a while you let it hard it
comes soft you have to let it harden
listen to me
i was at the apollos yesterday dude they
i wasn't even there for prosciutto i was
there to get stuff to make uh so what's
that what'd you get there what'd you get
there at apollos i bought italian
sausage to make to make dinner oh did
they started slicing prosciutto in front
of me dude it was everything in my being
to not order prosciutto that i didn't
need in that moment dude it is such an
elevated bee
prosciutto is a go-to punchline joke
meat on frasier
that's how high-class this meat is
here's how it is a reference on frasier
here's a serving sauce for prosciutto
two slices a month or you will die what
are you so salty you think that
ari look at what you just sawed off of
that
log
off of that circumcised you just put on
this table and sliced barely by the way
you might add barely
[Laughter]
is
no not the one you ate pig
give me my own piece
get
dude it feels like a scab it's so
[ __ ] good it feels like a scab
i mean if you say it's not good you're
moronic
of course it's good
that's hard romanian salami
straight from the [ __ ] motherland
the only thing that survived nazi
invasion was this recipe for the salami
it doesn't taste bad
say your thing like you want to say it
huh say your thing like you want to say
you know
pronounce it the way you pronounce it
prosciutto
that's not the way your people say it
how do they say it you know
i should have got it i know i know what
you're doing say it steve say you're
videos where they take people from italy
watching italian americans say italian
words
how do they say prosciutto like in
philly you we hear people say they'll go
give me a pound of prosciutto yeah awful
i have long hated the american practices
of dropping the vow from the end i hate
when they say mozzarella mozzarella is
another one
garbage humans worse to the whites
albanians i'll accept albanians
i've recently learned that albanians are
terrible also
first of all
far superior to that that's good yeah
that's good if you wanna if you gave me
a cracker that tastes like salami and
it's cheese some cheese together no no
i'm saying that tastes like a cracker
flavored like salami you see it can be a
top and a bottom this could be the bun
that you need
you can't eat that on a sandwich dude
you gotta you gotta do you come listen
i've tried this out for about two months
too long
so
it wasn't it was far soft before
that's like eating a tic tac dude it's
like when you who doesn't love a tic tac
yeah but i'm saying you can't make a
sandwich all right so you're admitting
that's not a great example
he brings a knife from home no it means
your knife
that's my knife yeah your dull [ __ ]
knife no just like your dull [ __ ]
intellect it's not dull dude look at
this thing dude you're cutting wood with
it
give me don't don't do that give me
another piece thanks
i will say this
i love salami this is a good flavor
salami's them however go ahead genoa
salami superior to this super soda
superior
superior to all of them no to all of
them dude you haven't had the right
prosciutto people you don't need to be
sliced paper i don't know
about it it has to be from the
region of italy listen it's not bad for
sure is not bad
prosciutto is very good
but but it's not a salami it's not as
it's like i said you just named three
different salamis okay i have a question
yeah is the
question being debated what's more
delicious or what what benefits is
what's better what's that better
it's an american overall it's been taken
by america i didn't even know prosciutto
was a thing for a while that's a sad
life i knew salami
it's because it's not kosher probably
because you were yeah you grew up kosher
and then also you were young
it's not a child's food no salami
salami could also be deli meat that's a
fourth type of salami people grew up on
salami lunchables won't give you
prosciutto yeah but that's disgusting
munchables couldn't afford prosciutto no
they can't afford prosciutto yeah i mean
what what kind of kid was eating for you
know what
one of my favorite things in life was
field trip lunch though like the extra
big lunch i would have like a nice
hoagie
chips i'd have a hoagie too but yeah not
a prosciutto ho dude but
here's the thing it's all about which
meat is a superior meat and i think yeah
like i think prosciutto is more
delicious but does that mean it's a
better meat overall no that's what i'm
trying to debate yeah think about that
who is more into price point children
when children get happier when they're
like hey we got some prosciutto hey we
got some salami who's reveling more
i want my buddy carlo once like he had a
special slicer that he came that big
giant red thing it was like
from italy you know one of those things
yeah literally paper thing you could
spin yeah yeah yeah you can do that with
these
if that prosciutto was the casual thing
i've ever tasted that was the absolute
best thing i ever had prosciutto is a
meat we have prosciutto on one
count it one sandwich here
all the other sandwiches have to carry
the weight for the prosciutto sandwich
no it's going to be about prosciutto
fairly with everything else that's
that's what good too expensive you're
saying it's not too expensive it's so
quality
the peanut butter jelly with the thing
is that's the thing no no i'm not it's
not about your favorite i'm talking
about the quality of a meat okay
prosciutto is you give salami to a kid
to shut them up you give them pieces of
lamb you go go over there and they will
shut up you give them a piece of
prosciutto they're just gonna be like
all right youtube it's like a [ __ ]
baby bottle with nothing in it you if
you all right let's talk let's by the
way let's talk origin countries yeah
prosciutto
france
wait prosciutto's france
there's french prosciutto there's
italian produces
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah let me finish spain
now let's talk something now let's talk
salami
romania and italy and italy and france
all the same things
what's french salami i don't know pork
salami no no which what's a french
salami i don't know what's the worst i
see two kinds of army what's a french
i've seen eastern europe saw me an
italian i'm only i'm
eating this on american slime american
salami that's our delicious well none of
them are american so then we're going to
have to go genoa
i mean china was your titan genoa salami
and then prosciutto department is my
type yeah yeah yeah that's the that's
the if you go to the prepackaged section
in the grocery store if you don't even
go to the dell if you if you want to get
basic [ __ ] here and you go to the most
accessible
simple way to get lunch meat go to the
prepackaged aisle of the grocery store
you're going to see one kind of
prosciutto and that's the parma and
you're going to see one kind of salami
and that is genoa and what countries are
those here
oh italy both so what's your point what
do you mean what's my point i mean what
so when i asked that oh so then so
you're talking about you said you want
to battle i'm sorry because you said you
want to battle american the american
versions of these so those are basically
the american versions these are the
italians
yes so they're both italian yeah but
that's not my point my point is it's
like an italian a [ __ ] mixing match
my point is
my point is
yeah let me break it into numbers so
you'll understand yeah yeah show me your
back hair while you make this point
[ __ ] [ __ ] guinea hold on dumb
[ __ ]
i'll bring you over to my side in two
seconds okay prosciutto makes more money
jew
[Laughter]
salami
no way there's salami everywhere salami
makes our money there's tiny 20
different types of salami
now listen to me if if we're going to
talk about the american standard of
these two meats genoa versus prosciutto
we're not okay yeah that's what you just
said salami but you i know but listen to
me yeah genoa versus de parma okay
that's not i don't agree with that
that's not the standards that's just
what you buy here in new york at the
beginning no i'm saying if you go to the
most basic place the most accessible
place in america to buy either of these
things those are the two versions they
have no just salami you just go to a
deli like give me salami give me a pound
of salami there's there's no such thing
as just salon yeah no i don't know i
know you're talking it's genuine so
that's what kids eat is generous yes
okay great so what's your point my point
is so then what we're battling here
truly if you want to break it down to an
american soil
so which one's the most cost effective
first salami is more accessible
prosciutto department is far superior to
generally no it's just more expensive
why would you get a more expensive uh
same quality thing it's just too
expensive
you can't have it on a sandwich every
day
i'll tell you why you'll go bro
you'll go broke yeah are you saying it's
the same deliciousness
yours cost too much you came in here
right now if you came in here right now
and if you said hey i'm going to serve
you okay hard prosciutto
everything bagel with peanut butter i'll
be like what else you got you go salami
like dude i'm gonna suck
listen to me because that is awesome and
we're finally friends listen to me right
they're fine if you
if you came into a forget this place if
you went into a restaurant yeah and they
and i was your waiter and you said we'll
take the charcuterie board i said okay
and i brought you
a board with cheese's olives and then
prosciutto department even the
pre-packaged thinly sliced kind on a
board that's the only kind versus
another board that had the
slices of genoa salami on it you'd be
like you wouldn't get any salami you
wouldn't go on a board he'd have a
different kind of salami it's versatile
it's versatile talking it's versatile
i'm saying you would have a different
kind of celebrity for that
titan versus titanium no you're saying
what would you go to a charcuterie board
and what's the lobby
for you
what do you want to do
we got that too what do you want to do
hey where's salami we got that you're
not lunchables there's fear we just
battled lunchables there is no salami
lunchable that can be no it could be
anything salami's versatile you're
saying
let's just do this
and then apply it to this one thing no
no no no no no
you could use it for lots of things
there's no so is there a salami
lunchable uh pimp i don't believe there
what is there just baloney
baloney which is your [ __ ] uh
third cousin okay that's hanging around
background alone in west virginia
[Laughter]
pepperoni pepperoni beat your meat into
a lunchable what else is there
yeah pepperoni well prosciutto's not
going on there because it's too classy
it's too expensive for a lunchable it's
too expensive for these kids
we're not putting salami in what other
meat will people eat and they said
what's the pepperoni this is the most
fraudulent of all faking italian meats
they go who pepperoni salami i would
maintain the most poser italian meat is
pepperoni
pepperoni
look i'm on pizza and it's like you're
not italian get out of here
not seeing a lot of mates well maybe not
the best example my point is yeah if you
go if you go most common places no you
can't go you just said you wanted to
though no no but you're saying this
here's just one thing it's a general
salami versus the [ __ ] whatever okay
but i'm saying we're versatile do you
want better oh do you want to apply it
to one thing i'll do you one better oh
what are you doing
what are you doing
i'll do you one better yeah go to any
deli counter in a supermarket
okay and i don't mean like i don't mean
do they have salami hold on yes hold on
a second okay i don't mean like uh i
don't mean like a west side market or a
place that's a little like foofier with
like an accommodation yeah philadelphia
middle of the road acme janardis
shoprite winn-dixie
you go to that deli counter
they got genoa salami and they got
prosciutto that's what they're serving
at your deli counter that you said that
we're all going to okay no no no no no
no that's what that's one place you can
get salami you're trying to say here's
the one type of salami and that's
judging on that outside of versatility
outside of specialty shops okay where am
i getting your salami let's how about
this uh lunch rooms
that's genoa salami great but can you
get prosciutto there what do you mean
lunch rooms i think i mean
that's right it's too expensive exactly
it's too expensive now would you say if
they were both the same price would you
still prefer salami over prosciutto i
say the versatility the versatility will
get you there the versatility we're
going to get versatility look versus
what do you get at katz's how many
different kinds of slimes you get
one kind of salami catches i don't like
the salami they have a cat i don't like
the salami of cactus and they have the
other and they have the balls yeah they
have the balls to charge 20 some dollars
for a salon
they charge 75 for a prosciutto sandwich
uh but but i go to katz's and i get
corned beef that's what i'm there to get
that's right
that's not the point my point is is you
want one argument if you're going to
argue for instance functionality of a
meat yeah that i'm going to argue
functionality on by me now granted your
meat is versatile yeah but it's not much
more versatile but i'll leave it at that
but let me just make my point if you
want to talk versatility
every deli counter in this country is
going to serve a couple types of
prosciutto i've seen it i go to these
supermarkets the types are the same it's
just a different place the same they're
different
nice whatever
but every one of these they look so much
different than the thick wide [ __ ]
floppy salami it's a good it's a
different thing you don't get a hard
prosciutto unless you unless you're
going to arthur avenue in the bronx yeah
okay and i would just specialty
or to especially jewish deli or
something it's hard to find like a
quality cured salami it's hard it's not
easy to come by but you can get an
accessible salami you can easily just
get a salami
salami i'm saying it's just a salami
sandwich absolutely anywhere you go and
i'm saying it's just as hard to find a
very high-end prosciutto but my point is
is i could find i could find a quality
prosciutto more easily than i could find
a quality salami and and now we're
talking generally you're talking about
you're going to talk about new york
you're talking about i'm talking we're
talking genoa salami or beef salami i
love both but those are those are
standard salamis there's nothing special
you think in montana you're gonna be
able to find a [ __ ] prosciutto
probably not probably not but you will
find yourself
you think in west virginia you're gonna
find quality prosciutto everywhere
you're not
but celebration is available san
francisco san francisco is a sandwich
town but philly is a sandwich san
francisco is as far as you could they
have the guineas
they have the whops san francisco is of
course literally as far as you can get
from new york italian east coast where i
feel like all the seeds of this stuff
gets planted and then and then it moves
out if it made it as far as san
francisco it's making it as far as but
you skipped over a bunch of middle [ __ ]
no montana doesn't have it they just got
their first italian restaurant i love
salami i love beef salami i love jello
salami i have a sandwich based on beef
and jello with salami they are amazing
salamis but my point is if you're saying
you're giving me a platter for these
meats to stand on their own so then you
would get kudo is a more quality meat i
can't how about this meat and cheese how
about this a meat and cheese platter you
want that thin salami like that you cut
off little pieces cut off little pieces
cut off little pieces prosciutto you
don't get that you already get already
sliced or forget it that's wrong how is
it wrong that's wrong how wrong you're
wrong there are different shapes of
prosciuttos yeah and you can cut the
meat however the [ __ ] you want to cut
how how i've only seen it in deli form
i've only seen it in deli meat formula
finley sliced trash
you you you l you live in squalor
i mean i mean it's a different
it's a difference between like i love a
hot dog yeah i love hot dogs i'll never
argue about dogs all day long but right
now we're arguing
a hot dog versus a coco sausage yeah
right
and you can't i can't in a million years
sit here and go as much as i love right
you're not getting all the cardboard
that i grill it's not a kobe burger
right right right right it's not
versatile it's not usable yeah a cold
bird is not useful huh coburg is not
useful i assure you you flip my argument
on me
right
no oh i don't know i was just i thought
that's what you're saying you can't get
you can't go to a yankee game and get a
cody burger
go to the game and say and get a
prosciutto sandwich you can get a salon
yes you can you know where you can get
it where
in the president's club when they write
you into that that's exactly what i'm
talking about it's too high scale the
common man can't get there dude we
didn't all get adopted by a rich family
some of us had to deal with the hand we
were dealt with they don't have some of
us were just born into a rich family
they they don't have salami sandwiches
at the ballpark i'm positive they do
they don't i promise you they don't
promise me promise you
i promise you when you get sucks
they got three things here at the
ballpark hot dog french fries chicken
fingers you can get a salami sandwich
there you can get a sandwich there you
can get a sandwich there you can there's
a sandwich place where so it's your main
argument
prosciutto more delicious salami more
accessible more versatile more
accessible also amazing
yeah it tastes a little better all right
that's your closing year sure it'll
taste a little better but really not
really it's only better because like you
rarely get it it's kind of like a split
pea soup it's kind of like a split pizza
we're like yeah it's always favorite but
you know what i mean salami i eat salami
all the time too great now
i'll go into some higher i'll go up to
the bronx and buy a high-end supersot
that hangs and drop delicious i'll do it
i can still only eat
five slices and i start to be like oh my
god like the fat content the saltiness
whatever i started everything whatever
prosciutto i ate two
packs of prosciutto last night
sitting in front of my tv disgusting
thinly sliced it was pre-packaged still
delicious i ate two full packs with baby
carrots because the sweetness of the
carrots you ever do melanin prosciutto
of course
they serve it as an appetizer in
restaurants and weddings dude if if you
ever
showed up to my wedding with salami i
would throw you out dude i can't i can't
get over the fact that you ate two packs
of prosciutto by yourself by the way
healthier healthier no keto one pack
dude salami's keto but one pack of
prosciutto is like 210 calories the
whole pack a pack of salami
so way more fat dude wow very fatty
prosciutto is very fatty it's one of the
fattiest meats there is no that's not
true
you can see fat in it you can see fat
you could eat around the fat if you
wanted to eat around the fat yeah you do
that last night pimp pimp
we're good on time right yeah
no i mean like how what time where are
we at
35 minutes okay my family give us
actually less healthier genoa salami
versus prosciutto
no no no no no no no no no you just you
have to name it the salami dumb [ __ ]
all right
forty-one calories for once
that's what you need to get by
calculating one units of energy
okay
that's not how much that's not what
here's my closing argument how about
weight he's looking at the calories hold
on no he's doing porn he started to look
it up and then he got sidetracked
in two things
yeah because you're supposed to two
slices a fence a thin slice tooth and
slice that prosciutto is even thinner
than one slice of salad no it's not it's
just not terrible slice that thin it's
like super thin because it's perfect you
can see through it i know you're being a
[ __ ] but that's a terrible argument
pimp
get take us to the pho let's hear what
some of the people are saying
oh hold on
i will say this here's my closing
arguments the people that didn't get to
close your arguments oh i thought you
did yours i thought no
no i did right now i said take us out
with some calorie accounts we have a
little more time okay so let me let me
go to the phones first okay go to the
phones and then we'll do closing
arguments okay i'm gonna have some
salami while i wait all right swami is
good salami's great it's
steve i mean it's look nobody's saying
it's not but that's not where we're here
with with tons of meat and and i'm the
only one who brought meat to this
the uh hold on well the fans don't like
it when we eat on mike they get mad well
if you're so angry why don't you take
that and go and donate to our brother's
keeper it's our new [ __ ] um all right
ready charity that gives porn to
homeless people stop it
do not you all know he's joking he's an
ass all right ready
salami is the dollar tree of cut meats
[Laughter]
prosciutto is the cadillac of sliced
meat salami is an old pontiac
you want people looking down on you like
those people who drop cadillacs you want
a one percenter you want a [ __ ] elite
illuminati then go get your prosciutto
if you want a person who's gonna take
over this country and lead the
revolution that's salami salami people
it's good compared to baloney
[Laughter]
the fact that there's even one vote for
salami here is outrageous
salami is amazing i'm also guessing joe
is team salami wrong
who would guess that prosciutto is only
good on charcuterie board salami is a
sandwich staple thank you that's what
i'm saying that's exactly what i'm
saying it's usable for everything all
right it is good for charcuterie boys oh
yeah a lot of people have charcuterie
boards that you get out of the mine
[ __ ] oh
canary died we lost a friend in the cave
in don't worry maul's got a charcuterie
board waiting for us salami is the
salami is disgusting joe i didn't pick
salami more like prosciutto no
yes
no prosciutto by a long shot salami is
the caviar taste beer budget option here
i've never had a good sandwich with
prosciutto you're having prosciutto
you're a bad prosciutto
let me make this clear
excuse me let me make this clear yeah
if prosciutto is not sliced paper thin
it is the most disgusting thing easy to
[ __ ] up a prosciutto impossible to [ __ ]
up salami i just sliced a a a 17 length
of [ __ ] whipped cream
still delicious yeah quality food should
always be like super easy to make you
know kraft mac and cheese quality
quality food right because it's super
easy
they weren't smuggling prosciutto on
their backs and heavy weights it was
salami baby thank you
salami is for people who don't wear
socks with bowling shoes
that's the winner that's the winner
that's amazing
all right follow that's our winner folks
follow at
uh
hathaway prof at hathaway prof professor
jeffrey hathaway fantastic work man
that's a solid one
um all right now it's closing arguments
time
listen when you grew up think about your
childhood your favorite days of your
life
think about it for a second legitimately
think about school and meeting your
friends and even like playtime and your
mom makes you a sandwich you come in
you know what that is that's a salami
sandwich
ketchup mustard or even possibly ketchup
and mustard it's up to you with salami
you can do whatever you want have it on
rye bread have it on white bread what is
it no one's allowed to i'm arguing
no one's allowed to have prosciutto with
ketchup you're just not allowed but
we're ketchup people you guys me and you
americans ketchup people till the end
vote team salami
my closing argument is
uh when you're young and you come inside
and you want a sandwich
and you start your mom grab
you grab for
the prosciutto your mom goes take your
disgusting hands off of that good
quality meat don't i have to slice it
i'm arguing okay all right here's the
salami make yourself a sandwich because
any philistine can put this between two
slices of bread and make it work that's
right everyone should have free shut up
philistine unlike what joe derosa wants
okay sorry prosciutto takes class it
takes time it takes effort it takes it's
it's more quality it tastes better it's
better for you
period prosciutto is the meat for the
people that care about themselves if you
care about yourself you care about
prosciutto
steve where does your final judgment
land all right this is what i really
love childhood right steve salami's
delicious one of the best things i ever
made
was uh i was going through a phase where
i was making pizza dough all the time
but i didn't feel like i had eaten so
many pizzas and i took
salami general salami it was paper thin
and provolone with some extra virgin
olive oil salt pepper and made a
stromboli it's one of the best things
i've ever had it was incredible
salami
is
phenomenal
but all things be it's but it's not a
treat
i don't know i think i i
i think i have to go with prosciutto
because all right i think it's just
better uh get your plugs out now this is
humble pie because once it ends it ends
plugs i would like to plug my new
podcast you'd be tripping you can
subscribe now my special's coming out in
october june but you'll be tripping
subscribe now and we'll go we'll go to
places and talk about foods yeah they'll
go to places that have stuff like this
you don't have to serve the thin as
possible to possibly enjoy it
uh i have a special that just came out
on dry bar called ice cream for
breakfast
you should play earlier too yeah
whatever i swear for breakfast steve
simone i know that bit for breakfast uh
special he's great
and uh i will plug uh well we're at
joeyrose's joeyrosesnyc.com for all
details tuesday through sunday we are
open come see us please for all kinds of
sandwiches
including both meats that we talked
about today
uh back on the road folks next spot
this week i will be in san diego
american comedy company september one
two three come see me got a bunch of
dates coming up through the fall after
that go to joederosainfo.com for uh all
info and show times and also new
podcasts coming soon down with joe
derosa i got one more me and joe me and
jay orgerson uh in vegas september 21st
one night that's fun
all right folks here we go humble pie
who won
pimp you want to tell us
oh
all right take
um in second place with 41
is prosciutto what
[Laughter]
that's perfect
that's perfect oh yeah
the people have spoken
back to italy
back with you to italy
down on your mortadelle boats and get
the [ __ ] out you just have to you just
have to say i still love you
i still love you joe i love you too
taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right